the definition of artificial general
intelligence is an autonomous system
that surpasses human capabilities well
the videotape I'm about to play for you
today titled rust in 100 seconds was
generated entirely by AI by combining
tools like gpt4 Puppeteer voice cloning
and ffmpeg but first over the last week
or so people have been freaking out over
these new self-prompting tools with
long-term memory like Auto GPT and baby
AGI they work by taking a single
objective from a human as a starting
point like build me a million dollar
business from there it will build a task
list and try to figure out how to
achieve that objective and it continues
to prompt itself over and over again
like a recursive function until the
actual objective is met under the hood
they're using open ai's GPT models and
also a vector database like Pinecone DB
to provide it with long-term memory so
it can keep track of what it's been
doing and naturally the first thing
people do with tools like this is modify
them to build things like chaos GPT to
establish Global dominance cause chaos
and destruction control humanity and
attain immortality sounds pretty crazy
so I tried these tools out for myself
and what I found they're most useful for
is making my open AI API calls go Burr
these projects are pretty fun but
nowhere near being true AGI however
there are other efforts underway like
hugging GPT from Microsoft or Jarvis
which uses an llm as a controller to
interact with other AI models on hugging
phase to create a more general purpose
AI tool then you have this new paper
from Stanford and Google research that
just dropped where they took 25 AI
agents and put them in a simulated world
and they actually produce believable
human behavior in other words they built
the Sims but all this got me thinking if
anyone's going to make me obsolete it's
going to be me so I built my own Auto
GPT from scratch with an S to your
programming language called JavaScript
it works by taking a video idea as an
input then uses gpt4 to write a video
script that's no big deal but here's
where things get weird it does a
secondary prompt to figure out how to
turn that script into an actual video
but to make a video we need assets like
images and code Snippets we need a voice
to narrate it and we need some kind of
program to render an actual video the
first thing I did was give gpt4 access
to puppets here a headless browser
that's often used for web scraping the
video script contains a bunch of code
code Snippets and for each one of them I
use Puppeteer to go to a site called
rey.so to generate a PNG for the code
but a video with only code would be kind
of boring so I also used a secondary
prompt with gpt4 to identify any people
or logos in the script and then return a
link to an image on the internet for
that graphic which could then be
downloaded and written to the file
system in addition to create a fireship
video you're also going to need some
animated gifs but for that I was able to
use the giphy API directly by having GPT
figure out what to search for with my
API key I performed this part in a bunch
of small steps allowing each part of the
script to correspond to a visual asset
that's pretty cool but we still don't
have anyone to narrate the video well
last weekend on Twitter this guy created
a program where you can link a YouTube
video and it will instantly clone that
YouTuber's voice so I'll go ahead and
give a demo by grabbing the neurosity
fireship video and then just putting it
into this site hi my name is Alim and I
like pancakes that's wild that's exactly
like him okay pretty crazy that's even
possible and it might be illegal but the
magic is made possible by an API called
11 Labs I went ahead and signed up and
cloned my voice using about two and a
half hours of recordings look at me I am
the captain of the Fire Ship now the
quality is decent but it can still be a
lot better now we can Loop over every
script file and make an API call 211
labs to generate the voice and then save
it as a WAV file and at this point we
have all the assets necessary to edit a
banger video now initially I attempted
to have gpt4 write its own ffmpeg script
to edit the video all by itself every
time it did actually work sometimes but
for the most part wasn't very reliable
we don't really need GPT for this part
anyway so I wrote some of my own code
with fluent ffmpeg to Loop over the
assets and combine them all together
into a single video and without further
Ado Here's the final result for your
viewing pleasure rust explained in 100
seconds rust is a programming language
that was created by Graden who
started working on it in 2006. Rust was
designed to be a safe concurrent and
fast language one ownership and
borrowing rust introduces a a unique
ownership system to manage memory
without garbage collection each value in
Rust has a single owner and once the
owner goes out of scope the value is
automatically deallocated two functions
and pattern matching functions are
declared with the FN keyword and Russ
supports pattern matching with the match
keyword that video only took AI about 30
seconds to create and had I not put made
by AI in the corner you guys would have
never known the difference at this point
I haven't released the code publicly due
to fears about the impact this would
have on Humanity but the good news is
that now that I've been flawlessly
cloned by AI I can finally stop making
AI videos and focus entirely on new
angular content thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one